so I saw Conan the Barbarian directly
after spy kids for I would have thought
that would have made Conan seem a lot
more better and it really didn't my
roster said I would meet you
he said our paths would merge whoever
noon tomorrow Amalia Jovie Kyra Sean and
yours Conan
that's it we made do I need Conan the
Barbarian stars Jason Momoa Rachel
Nichols Stephen Lang Rose McGowan and
Ron Perlman it's about this mystical
mask that's like needs to be assembled
from all different various parts that
have been spread over the world and
whoever gets the mask gets control over
its power whatever it's like if they
went to the mythological story pilots
like reached in there and was like ah
the same where they have to put things
together and they get his power Oh we'll
do that Jason Momoa is taken over there
Arnold Schwarzenegger role which from
the very beginning I thought was an
absolutely horrible idea do not remake
Arnold movies are doing you a Total
Recall right now I really like Colin
Farrell that's the only thing that makes
me think it could be good did Terminator
Salvation not good no this is awful film
I hated it I couldn't stand it actually
I actually fell asleep for about five to
six minutes in this movie I'm near the
beginning I just it's so horrible it's
really bad the action scenes are
incomprehensibly filmed once again we
seem to have a director who has
absolutely no idea how to shoot a film
in an editor who thinks that if you put
five different shots for one sword swipe
that it looks cooler than if you just
had a nice panoramic shot of two actors
fighting for a long take but you know
what they can't do that because that
takes planning and effort and
choreography another thing I hate about
this movie is the fact that Arnold can
say something and it's like on it's
awesome and that no other actor could
say like here's my reaction to watching
a scene from the first Conan movie crush
the enemies
see them driven before you they hear a
lamentation of the women ha ha ha
awesome that's fantastic
here's me reacting to the newer film
what about Berrien feels thirst it is a
thirst for blood our can say stuff that
no one else can say the original conan
wouldn't have been anything without
Arnold Arnold is it's Arnold for
goodness sakes can't do it I don't could
like go out and hunt and then come back
and be like I have returned with the
pheasant it's Madonna and it would be
fantastic Jason Momoa could come back
and be like I returned with the pheasant
it's for dinner it's gonna be great I'm
calling the Barbarian before I go on I
will give Jason Momoa some credit
because he had some energy his role you
could tell he was like trying to do a
good job this entire movie the script
and directing everything around it the
editing especially that dear Lord you
could just tell that everything was
against everyone on this movie yet all
the things that going on this movie the
production everything was just against
everything
things like to but that when we were
actually the prologue the opening was
Ron Perlman I thought Ron Perlman was
good that was actually the best part of
the whole movie Morgan Freeman narrated
it cuz apparently he's the go-to
narrator now they tried to be funny a
lot in this movie and just failed it
wasn't funny at all it seemed like they
tried to make Conan like really enjoy
battle in a kind of comical way another
thing about this movie that is so stupid
is it so obviously a Hollywood movie
because every one of these barbaric
actors who are like way way back in the
olden times we're supposed to be like
cavemen and are I kill everyone you'll
have perfectly straight like snow white
teeth they don't even have toothpaste
back then it's so stupid and some of
these characters like this girl look at
Rose McGowan here look at that makeup no
one back then puts on all that makeup
and everything it just the only people
who were makeup back then were like
savages and all I did was I've taken bun
and go back like all over their face no
one has like all these like perfect
little Hollywood makeup jobs oh it's so
horrible it was like the filmmakers and
the writers took this sense in the
mindset of the barbarian characters they
were trying to portray in the way they
made the movie that's like they took the
camera like look this is good a good
shot has been a really good shot
now this is a spoiler warning okay I'm
going to spoil a little aspect of the
plot so if you want to see the film
don't keep watching I don't know why you
want to see it but I'm just want to tell
you it here's a little bit of a warning
for you once Stephen Lang obtains the
mask of power and puts it on and
everything
nothing happens this power is increased
nothing happens they sword fight and
blah blah blah and it's like it meant
nothing like with the whole movie with
somehow cling to the mask about burns
did nothing okay Conan the Barbarian is
an awful movie and this was a really bad
day for movies for me I saw spike it's
four and Conan the Barbarian Wow I'm
gonna give Conan the Barbarian Adi
couldn't stand it
please don't see it hopefully the Total
Recall remake Total Recall remake that's
like a weird thing hopefully that'll be
good but if it's not please stop
remaking Arnold movies so if you liked
this review subscribe to my channel get
stockman eyes